what is up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio fantastic Fest
20123 I am here with the director behind
the closing film of the festival ninach
kakan for totally killer congratulations
thank you so much so happy to be here uh
Sasha Pearl raver is a collider Alum so
I've had my eye on this movie for a long
time now yes I love Sasha she's
here I know SAS we all know what I'm
doing after interview so there's many
things about this film that excite me
one I'm a big fan of your filmography
but this marks your first journey into
genre film making horror film making
specifically so I got a couple broader
questions about that cuz like we're here
clearly we love horror movies first what
was the very first horror movie that
terrified you
Exorcist definitely I thought it was
terrifying I guess you're going to see
the new one then I'm going to see the
new one I mean I have now there's two
Exorcist girls I'm quite excited about
that so that's the first movie that
terrified you to add another layer to
that what's the first movie that scared
you but where you were able to process
how special that kind of movie Magic was
where the power of horror film making
really kind of took hold and made you
appreciate
it great question I would say the ring I
definitely I thought it was
terrifying but I was also like this is
amazing and just like great storytelling
and Visually you know I was like
immersed in that world but then I was
like living alone at the time and I went
home that night and I like had all the
lights on and I couldn't go to sleep and
so normally I would turn on the TV but
if you've seen the ring can't turn on
the TV that wasn't an option so I was
just stuck just sitting there with the
lights on well it takes a lot to scare
me but one of the most recent horror
movies that I took home with me was
Paranormal Activity where I kind of like
laid in bed and the door the bedroom
door was cracked open and I just vividly
remember looking down the hallway
waiting for I don't know the bathroom
light or something to randomly turn on I
kind of like that feeling though it is
like it makes you feel alive yeah you
know like you're all you're firing all
your elements are on that's why I keep
coming back for more all right I'll
throw in one more question in this
particular category of all of I I guess
the classic horror movies out there
which one do you think you like real you
would have the best chance of surviving
mhh not many I'm going to tell you that
right now like for sure you know one of
the first to die in a lot of scenarios I
think I think what do I have the best
chance of
surviving maybe Nightmare on Elm Street
just because I feel like I feel like I
would just stay awake you know what I
mean like I don't think I would allow
myself like I feel like I had control in
that situation because I you know so I
would do whatever to like you were
saying you only drink coffee
yeah like that's what I would just do
that plus like I will preface this by
saying every single answer to this
question is wrong but I feel like
eventually your body just shuts down and
then you're screwed because Freddy is
there but I always pick things like you
know like running away from ghost face
cuz I know I can run no but even then I
know ultimately I'll be wrong and I'll
be overtaken Ghost Face will get me
that's it and as I'm overtaken I like my
last thought would be like I should have
picked nightmare Elm straight because
like I have more control I want to play
a little G I didn't write this game down
I hope I can remember some of these
questions but because you have such a
fun movie here with an incredible
Ensemble I want to put I want to put
some of them on the spot right now so
sometimes we play a slasher movie
Survival game so if I give you a couple
of slasher movie tropes I want you to
tell me which actor like the real person
best fits this descriptor okay who is
the most likely to to hear a strange
noise go and investigate and be the
first person to get killed by the
slasher Randall Park okay yeah I think
Randall Park I should have thought about
that a little more I feel like that came
too quick no that's what this is about I
feel like the quick answer is the honest
answer yeah who is the most likely to
trip and fall while running from the
slasher beside from me we're talking
about the cast trip and fall uh I don't
know I mean she's amazing in the movie
but maybe Julie Bowen I don't know I
can't wait to talk about a certain
sequence so good okay okay so Julia will
go for that one who is the most likely
to be the last one standing Kieran oh I
believe that Kieran for sure oh she's so
good she's so good Kieran shipka Legend
I mean already she's just she's gonna
you know she's going to be all the
things one day I believe that all right
I'll give you two more who's who's the
one who everybody thinks is dead but
shows up at the last possible second to
save the day right like remember me
that one oh yeah Olivia Holt yes
Olivia Holt for sure something about
this is aligning with their characters
quite well and I'm really into it here's
one of my favorite ones to ask who is
someone who would like walk into this
scary situation be like like F this I
don't like it and just leave just walk
away or give up maybe lyanna liberado
she might just be like I'm good she she
knows what she's doing though she's like
I've been here before I've been here
before and that's why she would like see
the signs and she'd be like turn around
good in Scream Six so good in Scream Six
loving the year she's having all right
let's get into some of your phography
now um so I was reading that after
always be my maybe you had a meeting
with Jason Blum was that the kind of
situation where you had an interest in
genre film making and went to him or he
had this script and came to you no that
was just like a general that was like
pre the script and it was sort of just
like you know they were fans of always
be my maybe I was fans of everything
they've done I was a fan of and they
were sort of just like let's figure out
something together like I like the idea
of mashups you know and after always be
my maybe I definitely I felt so happy
about what we accomplished with that
movie that I didn't want to do just
another straight romcom and so I was
looking to figure out like what the next
thing was so we were like let's keep
talking let's figure it out and then
totally killer emerged I mean I'm here
for another straight realm come from you
I'll take anything I mean maybe now I'll
go back to that you know I'll curve back
there I mean now that now that I'm
thinking about it I also want to be
greedy and keep you in genre making for
a long time so you know what was weird
this actually came from an ALT ending
that we shot from always being my maybe
I'm sorry no I'm just kidding I would
watch that I would watch that suddenly
this horror I mean there is some sort of
opport we've we've also like one of the
greatest things about fantastic Fest is
it just seems to be the kind of area
that like Sparks creativity and we just
keep thinking of like alt endings or
what a movie might look like if two
actors swapped roles and just like
experimenting and how that could change
everything now my mind is running wild
with creative possibilities there so you
have that meeting with blumhouse
two-part question on that when you walk
away from that meeting what is something
that made you think these would be
really great creative partners for me
and now having had the experience of
making a movie with them what is
something they did on totally killer
that you know helped you exceed your own
expectations for yourself as a director
I think blumhouse and everybody who
works there I mean the great thing about
them is they make movies like they love
movies and they make movies and I think
a lot of times you know certain
companies like it's almost like when
they make a movie they're like forced
into making a movie where it's like
blumhouse is like ready they're like
let's go let's make something and
they've got a real passion for it so I
think that was the the thing I took away
from that initial meeting of like oh
these people are down to like play and
have a good time and make something cool
um and then actually making totally
killer with them they were just so
supportive of like you know we have this
big like set piece in act three with
this Gravitron and we had to like go
find a Gravitron in Canada and like
shoot that practically and they were
down they were down for all of it they
were like we get it like this is it like
we got it you know and so they're very
supportive that way because they like to
make movies oh I have a movie Magic
question about that Gravitron before I
get too far ahead though I did want to
talk a little bit about time travel
roles because whenever you have a time
travel movie folks are going to sit
there and I get why they're going to
scrutinize every single rule that you
use in the film so maybe what is an
example of another rule you f you saw
another time travel movie play by that
you're like that works we want to hold
tight to it here but then I also want
like a time travel no no something that
doesn't work for you that you purposely
wanted to avoid well the thing that we
wanted to do here because like people
are so familiar with time travel and I
feel like you know there are so many
rules and people get into that you know
I wanted it to be that Kieran is also
aware of that you know so like she's
even referencing she goes back to 1987
but in ' 87 like Back to the Future the
movie has been released cuz that came
out in ' 85 so I think she's trying to
call upon like all these like kind of
references to other movies to help her
explain to people like what she's
talking about and why they're in danger
or whatever um and I appreciated that
because that felt real to me like if we
all went back we'd be like okay take
your favorite time travel movie and like
apply those rules kind of um and that's
kind of it but you know I mean I think I
think the idea of just not getting too
far down the Wormhole but a knowledging
like there are multiple and that's why
in our movie too it was fun to cut back
to present day during you know so Jam's
in the past but then it's still
affecting like seeing those links I like
that quality in real time quity and the
references too the scream reference any
scream reference will always make me
happy because of what you just said
let's say you as in real you time travel
back and you have to fight a slasher
something like that what time travel
movie rules are you abiding by most
which movie do you turn to that will
give you the best chance of surviving
that scenario I mean I think it's got to
be the classic Back to the Future I mean
Repo Man a little bit you know too but I
think like for sure back like I don't
want to mess with my parents you know
like I don't want to mess with anything
that's going to mess with me uh anyone I
know from the past or anything like that
I think I would be very cautious smart
smart roles to play by there all right
let's talk a little bit about Kieran so
I was reading I was reading in the Press
notes that your first meeting she just
got the character she loved the
character and she got it but I think
there was something uh there were little
things here and there that the two of
you could work on together can you maybe
specify some of those little things that
you worked on together to further hone
that character I think Kieran is such an
integral part of this movie obviously
she's the lead but she's playing so many
things at once you know so she's got the
fun of this time travel element and
she's you know back in ' 87 and she's
got to navigate that world as like a
genen z person from like 2023 but she
also has had this without giving too
much away this like very tragic event
happening in her life and so keeping
that you know not losing that thread and
I think that was the thing that she and
I as we went through the script were
sort of like where are we here like
there's all this fun going on all these
balls are in the air you know we're
keeping everything alive and you're
literally trying to you know run for
your life but like emotionally where are
you you know and I think like those were
the things that we were kind of tracking
the key to being able to have scares and
have fun but also have that really like
uh that grounded emotional through line
for a character like that that keeps it
just grounded enough exactly I
appreciate that quite a bit I also just
appreciate how incredible this whole
damn Ensemble is I wish I could sit here
and talk about everybody but because we
don't have time for that to touch on
maybe two people here of all the other
roles in the totally killer cast which
one was the easiest to find the perfect
fit for we like the right person just
magically came to you but then which
character of the bunch took you know the
most leg work the greatest search to
find the right actor for I mean I think
the first one is is Olivia for young Pam
you know I think seeing her
audition she just like embodied that
1987 like Alpha girl you know but in a
funny way like not you know she was all
of the things at once and then seeing
her and Kieran interact it was just like
that was it like I knew she was that
role I think um the other roles it was
really like filling out the rest of the
crew from the'80s because I wanted it to
be um just like the best actors you know
and so it was wide open and there's like
a lot of there's like red herrings going
on you know there's a killer on the
loose you know one of the you know if
you're familiar with the genre somebody
is the killer who is it and really
trying to hide the ball so really trying
to figure out who gives us that you know
like who could it possibly be like who's
the you know the misleads so really
putting together the ' 80s on sble I
think well hidden well hidden to add to
that a little and also because like
another thing I read in the notes I
think it was Terry Taylor was just
singing your Praises as an actor's
director and I always appreciate that of
everybody in this Ensemble can you maybe
name two cast members with completely
different approaches to the work where
they demand something different from you
as their actor's director um I mean
Charlie Gillespie who plays young Blake
uh is like such a like free spirit dude
and so like he and I would just talk
about like soulful energy of like scenes
you know like he's not he wasn't really
about like the actual thing but sort of
the vibe of things description you know
and I was like okay like great like
let's talk about let's talk Vibe you
know um so that's the one spectrum and
then you know you have other actors that
are you know kind of more like okay
let's talk through the lines and let's
like figure out you know but also I
would say like the young actors from the
80s um you know Anna and Stephie and
everybody who plays like the Molly's
like they were all I mean everybody's so
young so it was like really like dialing
in the exact right Vibe for they make
sure it didn't feel like they were
acting 80s but rather like living there
you know I do have another this is very
very specific I don't know if you're
going to remember an exact line here but
one of the things that impressed me most
about their performances is there are so
many lines in this movie where if you
don't deliver a Pitch Perfect uh if you
don't do a Pitch Perfect line delivery
it it sounds false and also not funny
but they sell these lines so incredibly
well can you maybe pinpoint a specific
example to tease for our audience where
I don't know and you were worried about
a line and the way that it came out on
the day just blew your mind and it
worked better than you ever could have
imagined I mean I was just so lucky to
work with like an incredible cast truly
and you know they're so funny but also
like could pivot right to the scream
Queen element of it you know there was
this one line I think when they're going
to the cabin kind kind of in the middle
of the movie and they're reminiscing
about their friend and they start
talking about how she hated giving
and they were but the delivery
was so like empathetic and like wistful
and that just made me laugh out loud you
know just sort of like you know I mean
talking about your friend like the one
of the qualities of like your greatly
missed friend and that you know she
hated giving blow JNS that was a good
call back that was a good call back
there also all of uh kieran's comments
about what is what is not appropriate
anymore that's happening in the 80s I'm
like oh those could have like landed
with a th but she made them work so
incredibly well she was so great at that
and also because it's like we're not
trying to say one is right or one like
she's just saying like this you can't do
this anymore you know and people were
like what are you talking about like
there is no such thing as
pcness uh but she she like really
handled that with like a deaf touch very
much so really made the most of what was
on the page there I loved it all right
we got to talk about that mask I I guess
one of the things that I'm most curious
about is did that mask go through any
kind of evolution what is the biggest
difference between the first type of
mask that was presented to you and what
it wound up being in the finished film I
mean we went through a lot of iterations
you know because as you know like
slasher movie you really got to nail
that mask um and I think that you know
starting from the place of a handsome
man and then sort of being like okay
what does that look like and then you
know once we landed on that idea that it
was sort of this like compilation of
like let's pull all these references
with these like ' 80s heart throbs and
then Tony Gardener and his team at
alteron like they just started to like
composite stuff and so seeing all those
versions of everything and then like
leaning into like the fun of it a little
bit with like The Lost Boys element like
that earring you know so it's like a
little like touch of Camp you know but
still scary and just like a a handsome
man smiling like that with like the chin
think like I don't know it all sort of
started to evolve and it was like okay
now we're liking this we're liking this
element He had to be blonde for so
whatever reason everybody was like that
makes sense um but yeah it was a really
fun process it's a very effective look
very memorable too that's always what
you want with a a slasher movie killer
you want to walk away and be thinking
about that mask and hoping that people
wear that mask during Halloween I mean
that would be amazing I would like to
see that all right my two movie Magic
questions now first I want to you
brought up the gra chel I'm not going
there for I want to ask about the
DodgeBall scene what is the movie Magic
behind shooting a dodgeball scene how
much is practical and how much is
digital so you can you know capture the
creative nature of what it is to play a
dodgeball game that was such a fun
sequence to shoot we worked with our
stunt team Simon Bernette who's our
stunt coordinator so we have like stunt
performers in there and then we have our
actors in there and we tried to shoot as
much practically as we could and then we
would add there's just a couple shots
where I just wanted more dodgeballs
flying we
addition Doge balls just flying through
but the actual like hits and all that St
that was all practical um and it just
like I wanted it to feel like you know
like that scene from Saving Private Ryan
when they get off the boat and it just
like chaos the chaos of War very
successful I always wonder about that
when I watch dodgeball scenes how much
is actually real all right so now back
to the graviton part how much of that is
real is it actually spinning it I'm
asking you a million questions is it
actually spinning it at all and what is
it like directing actors if it's not
spinning and they can't feel the force
in order to make it look like they're
feeling the force of the Gravitron
there's so many elements that so it was
like a real Gravitron that we found from
some
cares in Canada we brought it onto the
stage we had three days to shoot that
final sequence and so wherever our
camera is pointed like the part that
you're not seeing panels are taken out
cuz we've got our cameras in there so
the Gravitron itself is not moving but
our DP Jud Overton and his team had a
lighting rig going outside because
there's like small cracks in between the
panels so you can see the lights moving
and that suggests movement and then we
have the Practical effects guys in there
with
blowers uh to blow back you know so your
hair like that effect of being stuck to
the wall is going on but that can only
play when dialogue is not playing so
because that would not be good for sound
you know that everybody's got the their
element in there uh and we have wire
work you know we've got the stunt
um going so when they get thrown back
that's wires pulling everybody back um
and it's just all choreographed we like
storyboarded that sequence we rehearsed
it we did previs for it so we knew
exactly how do they get on what's the
when the machine starts go you know when
she presses the button it starts moving
the do still open how fast does it start
going then when the door closes then it
picks up speed so it's like all that
kind of you know yeah it's crazy it's so
perfect for this movie it like watching
scenes like that immediately like
brought me back to being a kid and going
on a grabit which always seemed like the
most dangerous thing so dangerous like
the the thing with like the least
oversight and you you make a nod to that
too where I'm like nobody's actually
watching these kids to make sure they're
behaving on this ride right now any ride
where you're not locked in by something
you have no seat belt or strap or
harness you're just like well here we go
like I went on that ride a million times
as a kid I loved it um I don't want to
spoil one of your first big chase scenes
but it is incredible and it does have
very successful like classic slasher
Chase Vibes having done that scene and
done it so successfully what is one do
and one do not you would tell another
director about to direct their first
slasher Chas scene I think really
working through it's like the
choreography of that and also like how
do you want it to feel you know for me
like a reference like Atomic blonde made
a lot of sense because I I think for
some reason when like when women are
fighting I think being close to them
having the camera close and giving a
sense of intimacy helps those sequences
and it makes you feel because you put
yourself or maybe it's just me but I
feel like I'm right there and I feel
like oh like how what would I do um
so I think you know and a lot of action
sequ like beautiful action sequence
Mission Impossible you have those wide
shots and it looks amazing but I would
just be like what's the feeling you're
trying to you know get through here and
and convey you have quite a few good set
pieces here too thank you I'm like I'm
like trying so hard not to go too far
and spoil anything and like there's
certain things like maybe a water bed
mention in our press notes which is it
that's another like movie Magic one
that's quite the feat I'm so uh excited
for that one for people to see that
because like that is also that was a
practical location that was a lovely
couple's house that we were like
shooting in and we had to like construct
our own water bed so our production
designer Liz Kay like made this th you
know this kind of flat that went over
the bed and we had all this like you
know as as many practical uh elements as
we could so you'd actually stab it the
water is actually going we had blood
capsules in there and then you would
enhance it in the post but just you know
it always just looks great as much as
you can get is that something you can
only shoot once and hope you get it or
is it or can you actually reset that and
do it again if you reset that I mean
that would have been like a whole other
day so you'd have to come back the next
day we shed that we shut that one so we
had I think five cameras going that's
that's the way to do it if you have to
yeah so so good I want to end on one big
broad fantastic Fest question because I
know you've been here a couple of days
and again one of my favorite things
about being at this Festival it's just a
whole bunch of horror movie lovers and
people who are really supportive of one
another and also an environment where it
feels like I keep talking to people who
feel inspired by what they're seeing
here so of everything you've seen at
Fantastic Fest can you pinpoint a
specific something another filmmaker did
that you you know thought to yourself
like wow that inspires me to swing that
big in the future I mean I think like
for it's it's funny I think because I've
been living in the 80s world with this
movie I saw a movie yesterday from 1984
that was shot on all camcorder uh called
blonde death have you seen it I have not
seen it but I looked at the list and I'm
like oh no I'm sad to be missing that
here I absolutely loved it and I just
think like the tone of it it's so funny
again like there's stuff in that movie
that you could never do today you could
never say today but just the uh sense of
awareness that that movie had and you
know they were making it for themselves
almost and that confidence I just loved
it I just thought it was so funny so
well done and so inspirational I love
hearing it I love hearing it I love The
Vibes here and I love your movie thank
you I'm not going to tell you how many
times I've watched it cuz I'll probably
get in trouble if I admit that but
congratulations un totally killer I
appreciate that thank you so much
everybody out there do not miss it trust
me you're going to love it and stay
tuned we'll have more from Fantastic
Fest 2023 for you very very
soon